we've got our tools to play with
equipment weapons maps and modes though
let's get into this one uh let's get
into uh the design team you know the
philosophy uh i suppose behind building
out maps but jeff this is for you um
yeah you know right from the start we
knew we wanted to build a big another
big map um not only for battle royale
but also for this other mode that we've
been working on for uh quite a long time
um
i read about that on the internet oh yes
but you know when when you lay out these
big maps it's kind of a collection of
all these little pois these points of
interest and um within each of these
we've really fine-tuned that they can
play core large-scale core modes like
ground war
and a bunch of others
really well
and so
you know stepping back from this large
map and looking at how much open world
sandboxy gameplay that we have we looked
back at our 6v6 maps and really tried to
refine and uh make them a tighter
experience to contrast all this big
world um kind of exploratory gameplay so
the maps uh for 6v6 in comparison to the
last game they're just um a little bit
more straightforward a little bit more
refined and
i think fans will really enjoy how
quick they play that sounds a lot of
diversity in those maps as well a lot of
visual variety some colorful maps in
there and um they i think they they feel
really clean
guys you're moving me in ways i didn't
imagine to be moved today excellent
stuff
we've got some of the maps that we are
going to be seeing in mw2 uh starting
with one uh we've got a real fun one
here guys this is one of the
aforementioned battle maps uh team can
you give me some details on sarif bay
so sarif bay is this little fishing town
um in the south coast of our big map and
it we picked this because it has such a
great mix of gameplay
it's right on a harbor so we get to show
off all our boats and our new amphibious
apc um and you know swimming as we've
already said
but what you get inside the town is this
really intense urban combat with all
these tight little alleyways and uh all
this great rooftop combat and mixed with
our ledge hang you get these really cool
parkour combat um uh action happening
yeah i love how you describe the uh the
rooftops there on this map specifically
as like a separate ecosystem you can
kind of migrate that entire vehicle go
up there and just
hang out and fight other snipers
all right well that looks fantastic jeff
okay so that's one of our larger maps uh
what about some of the 6v6 maps i think
we have we have some footage of one of
the new maps that we're going to be
seeing today uh named mercado las almas
uh do you mind giving you some details
on this one sure micarta is um
is a little street market in a historic
section in mexico
our story behind this is uh you know the
authorities have some intel that
narcotics are being smuggled out of a
warehouse and they're going in trying to
find and seize them
this map plays really fast and a lot of
action right down that center lane
the mercado is a very dangerous
neck of the woods so watch out when
you're playing in the beta it plays fast
i cannot wait really can't wait it looks
fantastic and again uh interesting to
see uh you know how that ties into
campaigns and whatnot all sorts of fun
and games ahead of us looks amazing
battle maps core maps 6v6 all this looks
fantastic but let's go back two modes so
we've seen some maps